martin biron michel david louis blouin
bonsoir
louis on vous invitez vous avez signé un
texte fort intéressant ce matin
habituellement ce genre de textes qu'on
a vu beaucoup puis quand j'étais sur les
collines ce genre de texte prophète mais
les gens ne parlent pas à visage
découvert or il ya des députés du parti
libéral du canada qui en ont marre
d'être oubliés depuis la campagne
électorale je vous je cite deux trois
extraits de votre article nathaniel
député libéral
le caucus était consulté tous les jours
à propos de la réponse face à la
pandémie maintenant nous annulons une
prestation d'urgence il n'y a même pas
une rencontre du caucus pour moi elle
est là la frustration vous at il dit
alexandra mendes député de brossard je
trouve ça étonnant vous dit elle ça fait
plus d'un mois que l'élection ait lieu
et puis quelqu'un qui lui a préféré
rester anonyme qui vous est notre député
ou une aux députés j'aime bien jaser
avec les journalistes de radio-canada en
faisant de france avoue j'aimerais mieux
être en train de sièges au parlement
l'airé des livres à écrire sur comment
monsieur lange journée monsieur chrétien
se charest entre aude dorloter leur
caucus puis s'en occupait je trudeau en
tout cas depuis l'érection
il crée des mécontents je dirais qu'il
ya une certaine frustration patrice de
voir les choses c'est tirer comme ça
depuis le scrutin du 20 septembre 2
frustration principales la première
c'est qu'il a toujours pas eu de réunion
officielle du caucus national des
libéraux où tous les députés se
rencontrent pour faire par exemple une
rétroaction sur la dernière campagne des
députés qui me dit écoutez nous on a
entendu plein de choses aux portes des
électeurs ça une valeur tout ça il faut
communiquer son parti il faut commune et
ça au premier ministre à la ministre des
finances puis la deuxième crue situation
c'est que il ya des décisions qui se
prennent sans que le caucus soit
consulté je vais vous donner un exemple
c'est la fin de la pcr la fameuse
prestation de la relance économique qui
a été annoncé par madame puis nantes la
semaine dernière ben 10 buts et on n'a
pas entendu parler de ça alors que
monsieur hawkins mythe que on a vu la
situation lui dis moi j'aurais aimé ça
qu'elle reste cette prestation elle
demeure pertinente il dit si il avait
écouté le caucus mais probablement qu'il
l'aurait maintenu encore cette
prestation laisse quand même des fois
mais en tout cas il y aurait coûté
caucus j'ai eu un débat qu à jour
certaines et il ya des gens qui se
disent aussi là et on a compté j'ai même
compter les cases dans mon calendrier
patrice 62 jours vont être écoulés entre
le scrutin du 20 septembre et la reprise
des travaux le 22 novembre si on compare
ça ou et vous allez 2015 2019 c'était 44
jours alors c'est quand même notablement
plus long il ya les députés qu'ils il
n'y a pas vraiment de raison à ce moment
pour que ça prenne autant de temps avant
qu'on revienne dans deux fonctions comme
si un michel david et martin biron comme
si monsieur trudeau là il a créé son
nouveau conseil des ministres qu'il veut
le plus efficace possible pour aller le
plus loin possible possiblement dans son
dernier mandat comme si les députés pas
été accessoires mais dans sa ligne d'un
tir était moins et est moins utile
peut-être michel oui c'est l'impression
que ça donne bien évidemment mais vous
savez pendant cap un électoral l'on voit
monsieur trudeau on voit les chefs de
partis
bien occupé mais les députés il
travaille fort aussi pendant une
campagne électorale est dans l'ordre des
choses qu'on fasse au moins un bilan
après l'élection avec les avec les
députés qui ont été réélus mais
généralement aussi avec ceux qui ont été
défaits et ça monsieur trudeau mais
toute évidence avais pas très envie d'en
entendre parler et d'autre part c'est
les députés qui sont le relais du
gouvernement avec la population avec
leurs commettants l'heure quand on prend
des décisions c'est eux qui sont pris
pour les expliquer alors si on pourra
était parti de la décision si on ne
m'aime pas entendu parler avant de lire
les journaux ou d'écouter le bulletin de
nouvelles bah évidemment si frustrant et
vous avez donné l'exemple de demandes
rhône et chats auraient déjà des chefs
qui était très très près de leur caucus
l'homme suit trudeau et fraîchement
réélu il ya pas de problème immédiat
mais j'ai pas dit que dans un an deux
ans il se retrouvera pas dans dans le
trouble et c'est à ce moment là que
l'appui du pôle gims caucus devient
indispensable pour un chef et si on
mécontente les députés une fois deux
fois trois fois comme ça quand cathy le
chef leurs appels au secours bailly ont
autre chose à faire il ya des chefs pour
qui c'est plus naturel disent penser
comme ça se retrouvant en gros de les
faire participer de leur donner de
l'importance martin de pau simplement
leur dire vous êtes arrière-ban vous
avez vous compté paul va prendre une
décision sans consulter
son caucus c'est périlleux
souvent les décisions sont prises par
l'entourage du premier ministre dans un
vase assez clos mais ça doit être mis au
jeu ça doit être discuté il ya des gens
pour spin et dans les réunions du caucus
pour essayer de convaincre les plus
récalcitrants
mais en même temps comme chez le disais
c'est c'est le lien avec le terrain là
c'est tout c'est tous des émissaires
dans leur circonscription le redis ce
qui se passe sur le terrain alors il
faut effectivement les consulter sur
monsieur trudeau sur six pense
actuellement moi de mon siège à québec
on le sent assez hésitant monsieur
trudeau en est et si son troisième
mandat les députés dans un premier
mandat et il était majoritaire alors là
ils se tiennent un peu plus les faits
serré jouent le jeu mais rendu au
troisième mandat si nous à notre bout de
la lorgnette on le sent hésitant les
députés le sang aussi hésitant et ça
fait des députés beaucoup plus bavard et
6 il ne prend pas le contrôle de son
caucus rapidement je pense que louis va
être pas mal occupé à interroger députés
dans les prochaines semaines auquel web
et remercie ceux qui veulent lire ça
c'est sur notre site radio-canada info
donc c'est intéressant ça montre une
frustration réel entre abstrait on peut
pas dire assez des anonymes visage puis
des gens qui parlent ouvertement
merci merci louis je vous fais la course
passion à ce panel s'est apprécié là on
change de capital québec
il ya eu cette bisbille r et u 7 bis b
hier au sujet de la santé je bats arrête
je vous exprime le contexte pour écouter
ensuite les si vous étiez pas avec nous
hier monsieur barrette qui s'est fort
que lui évidemment donne son avis sur la
négociation que les médecins
généralistes on regarde le tweet alors
ils lancent hier docteur godin prononce
les mêmes mots quand même qu'en 2015
quand il s'est engagé inscrit 85 % de la
population ne le croyais pas et c'est
donc tweet aurait pu émaner du
gouvernement cac et donc peu agressive
d'un côté et la sa collègue libéral dit
non non non monsieur bart est cher cher
guitare ou cher docteur ce tweet est
aussi peu productifs que l'attitude
autoritaire et les menaces de françois
legault dante petite crise au caucus
libéral réunion hier et marthe et on va
écouter ce matin madame anglade qui dit
j'ai expliqué à madame montpetit le con
qu'on doit se serrer les ferrer l'icône
serrer les rangs radicaux
c'est une chose que je ne fais pas comme
vous pouvez le constater ces deux pommes
musée mais députés au contraire
contrairement aux députés d'en face de
la coalition bois québec mois mais
député s'exprimer s'expriment librement
la seule chose que je demande c'est
qu'il ya une solidarité sans faille de
la part de mes députés
l'ouvragé a dominé câble c'est la
journée dominique anglade laquelle
s'occupe de main à mon psy monsieur
benjamin
martin monsieur legault en profiter pour
pour envoyer les projecteurs sur madame
à ryad alors qu'est ce que c'est demain
c'est tout oublié tout ça où il ya une
gestion je me suis paraître il ya
négocier avec les médecins c'est sûr on
a envie de savoir ce qu'ils pensent
il ya beaucoup de choses dans seul mais
et puis tout le monde a à peu près ses
torts d'abord serait dû se régler dans
le bureau de dominique anglade dominique
anglade la réputation de pauvres loin se
mêler de ces des chicanes de ses députés
dits parlez vous réglez vos affaires
mais dans ce que si ça fait un moment
qu'elle aurait dû régler le froid entre
guette en barrettes l'ancien ministre de
la santé et marie montpetit qui la porte
parole en santé dure depuis bien
longtemps mari mon petit trouve que
gaétan barrette se mêle de ses affaires
il joue dans ses plats demande marie mon
petit et me garder son carré de sable
bien insérés ne le consulte pas c'est à
peine s'ils se parlent alors monsieur
barrette a effectivement tout était ou
pris une position que son propre caucus
n'avait pas pris et c'est ce qui est
fixé solidement mari mon petit mais
c'est comme un conseiller me disais
c'est comme compter dans son propre but
et est assuré que la lame du patin est
assez proche du visage qu'elle peut
couper là là lol
blessés carey price alors c'est sûr que
ça atteint dominique anglade que toutes
les misères du monde à bien vivre dans à
bien garder la salle à la discipline
dans son caucus mais en même temps
guette en barrettes il est conspué dans
le caucus la réforme barrette c'est des
mots tabous pour les libéraux alors
monsieur barrette y voit une opportunité
là que lui non monsieur legault de se
refaire
bichot la scène politique avec un petit
peu plus d'un an il nous dit en entrevue
puis derrière on parlait de la centaine
entrevue la semaine dernière ici cette
antenne donc michel monsieur barrette
devient
devient un caillou dans le soulier
madame anglade très évidemment écouter
et monsieur boire est d'ailleurs alors à
pied alors de madame montpetit mais
l'heure est toujours à pied alors
monsieur bart est lui aussi parce qu'il
se mêle pas de ses affaires je comprend
très vite mais ce bar est veut défendre
sa réforme mais à chaque fois qu'ils
interviennent ils s'en prive pas ils
sapent la crédibilité de madame mon
petit un moment donné on sait que ceux
qui vraiment la donne l'heure juste
parti libéral à ce que c'est madame
montpetit où c'est monsieur barrette et
souvenez-vous pendant la pandémie alors
que l'assemblée nationale par moment ne
siègera pas monsieur barrette avait
beaucoup de visibilité les médias
appeler monsieur bart est
alors c'est monsieur bara qui était le
monsieur santé du parti libéral et là on
a vu les tweets mais ce qu'on voit pas
c'est ce qu'il ya derrière je ne doute
pas un seul instant que monsieur
barrette ne se gêne pas pour dire à
madame montpetit ben non là ça sera pas
dans l'oeuf ce que tu dis là puis on
l'avait vu son son côté paternaliste
pour pour employer un mot gentil à
l'endroit par exemple de madame de la
mort qui était le seul vis-à-vis
péquiste à l'époque c'est bien on se
pose mais il ya la manière et monsieur
marette ne choisit pas toujours la bonne
mais la raison pour laquelle dominique
anglade a donné la tape sur les doigts
de mari mon petit plutôt que de gaëtan
barrette c'est que le caucus était
derrière guettant barrette la réunion de
ce matin qui était plus importante que
celle d'hier les députés estiment que
monsieur barrette a mis en place une
réforme qui a été adopté par les
libéraux et qu'il ya personne qui prend
les balles pour lui alors que quand même
la réforme barrette et dans l'actualité
régulièrement alors c'est madame anglade
on est obligé de répondre à son coq est
bon mais c'est ce que j'aimerais vous
poser une chaîne sur le prenons juste la
partie de négociation avec les médecins
il ne prenons pas tout la réforme barret
depuis l'aller la restructuration les 6
et tout ça mais sur la source son
attitude qu'il voulait avoir avec les
médecins est ce que les libéraux adopte
son aide sud ou pas c'est ça qu'on veut
savoir de madame anglade elle se situe
où est-ce qu'elle appuie l'action dans
la lecture ou pas c'est une excellente
question moi je pense que madame
réglages à un moment donné va dire
écoutez c'est pas la bonne façon de
faire les choses parce que la politique
finalement du gouvernement couillard ça
avait été de ne pas appliquer la loi 20
que monsieur legault semble vouloir
être apprêtée à une nouvelle chose alors
j'ai l'impression que l'étude des du
parti libéral ça va te dire écoutez
l'arrêter le jo matamore assoyez vous
avec les médecins puis trouver une
solution parce qu une guerre avec les
médecins d'abord on la regarde pas
souvent et ça laisse des séquelles oui
c'est ça martine le choix de la chef la
wii l'info constitue dans ce débat là
est ce que je suis plus une passe
querelles la douceur et la lenteur
c'était ça y est là mais c'est ça c'est
le fond de l'histoire est encore
aujourd'hui elle a tergiversé sur cette
question là alors quelle est la position
du parti libéral la solution du parti
libéral pour que les québécois les 880
milles québécois est accès à un médecin
de famille est là elle ne parle ni de
méthode sur nine de méthode forte elle
ne parle pas de la fédération des
médecins omnipraticiens et laisse tout
ça dans un espèce de flou et le caucus
ces pressions également pour en discuter
et ça ne se discute pas au moment
vraiment dans le caucus qu'un discutent
de ce imaginer barrette doit pas être
capable de s'empêcher de prendre la
parole puis d'écouter il connaît les
moindres détails de tous les détails de
ces négos l'heure alors mal à mon p'tit
loup et frustre effectivement ça mais je
répète peut-être que ce n'est pas la
méthode dure qu'il faut employer que le
médecin que j'ai david mais il faut
avoir une position dure est ce qu'on
veut des gains on veut pas de gain dans
le nombre de patients qu'ils ont
évidemment il va falloir qu'ils aient
une position plus claire que ça mais je
pense que ça va être une position qui va
être à l'encontre de celle de monsieur
legault parce que le maintenant deux
partis libéral et dans la pollution
alors j'ai eu envers le projet de loi
que le gouvernement va présenter mais je
suis convaincu que l'opposition va
trouver de moyens dès que c'est pas la
bonne façon d'agir
mais c'est en fait le lieu il me suit le
goût dit souvent aussi que le lober est
très puissant de la fmq mais c'est
vraiment les médecins spécialistes qui
est le lober le plus puissant et le plus
riche aussi souvent lalala fm au cul est
beaucoup plus le beh je dirais remorque
là c'est lui qui passe après et qui
récolte alors là on voit vraiment on va
voir de quel bois se chauffe l'afm au
cul dans ce dossier là et l'impression
qu'on a chez françois legault et on a
sans doute fondés sur cette question là
c'est que le crayon public et de son
côté et veut mater
ça c'est très intéressant martin les
gens du change effectivement plus les
gens voulez vous qu'on ait ligne dure
envers les médecins pour qu'ils voient
plus de manches sur tout le monde a dit
oui mais quand les l'un des médecins
commencent à parler et on s'aperçoit que
c'est peut-être un peu plus compliqué
que ça et là des médecins qui sont
beaucoup plus à l'hôpital au québec en
ontario dans le diable est dans les
détails mais celle d'un disque 1
il faut voir d'où ça vient cette
situation là si on fait un peu
l'historique c'est que
les médecins ont été forcés pour une
grande partie d'aller travailler dans
les hôpitaux un moment donné on avait
imposé à tous les médecins de moins de
10 ans de pratiquer un certain nombre de
ce qu'on appelle les activités médicales
particulières ont négligé à aller à
l'hôpital pour faire de l'urgence du
suivi de passe etc alors il ya eu un
déplacement oui vers les hôpitaux qui
sont devenus très que le système est
devenu très hospitaliers aux centristes
là on veut des faire ça mais il reste
qu'à l'origine c'est les gouvernements
successifs qui ont créé cette situation
là gros ménage à faire merci beaucoup à
vous deux bonnes soirées avoir à bientôt
on va